the blockchain is a term that has come
to mean many things to many people
for developers it is a set of protocols
and encryption technologies for securely
storing data on a distributed network
for Business and Finance it is a
distributed ledger and the technology
underlying the explosion of new digital
currencies for technologists it is the
driving force behind the next generation
of the Internet for others it is a tool
for radically reshaping society and
economy taking us into a more
decentralized world
whichever way you look at it blockchain
has become a term that captures the
imagination and fascinates many as the
implications of such technology are
truly profound for the first time in
human history people anywhere can trust
each other and transact with in large
peer-to-peer networks without
centralized management trust is
established not by centralized
institutions but by protocols
cryptography and computer code this
greatly strengthens our capacity for
collaboration and cooperation between
organisations and individuals within
peer networks enabling us to potentially
form global networks of collaboration
without centralized formal institutions
unprecedented but hugely relevant in an
age of globalization and a new set of
21st century challenges that require
mass collaboration
Chane is a complex technological
economic and social phenomenon it calls
into question what might have seemed to
be established parameters of the modern
world like currency economics trust
value and exchange to make sense of this
one needs to understand it in a holistic
context all the way from its
technicalities to it's aspirational
potential this course is designed to do
exactly that by giving a 360-degree
overview to the different dimensions of
the technology its potential application
within various industries and its
far-reaching implications for society
and economy
in the first section of the course we
give an overview to the blockchain both
on a technical and non-technical level
we also discuss the importance of the
blockchain within the context of the
emerging next-generation Internet
in the second section we talk about the
blockchain as a so-called trust machine
and how it enables transparency and
collaboration we will look at
distributed ledger technology talking
about smart contracts etherium and
decentralized applications
in the third section we introduce you to
the workings of token economies
illustrating how the blockchain and
distributed Ledger's can work to build
vibrant ecosystems through the use of
tokens to incentivize behavior
section of the course we will be looking
at specific applications of the
blockchain to economy society technology
and environment looking at both existing
practical applications and potential
future applications
the blockchain is a so-called emerging
technology that is currently
experiencing very rapid evolution within
the space of just two or three years it
has already gone through changes in its
technical implementation and our
understanding of what it is and can be
as such our aim is to future-proof this
course by not dwelling excessively on
existing technical implementations but
presenting a more conceptual
understanding of the blockchain within
the broader process of change of the
emerging next-generation Internet
is much more than a technology it is
also a culture and community that is
passionate about creating a more
equitable world through decentralization
it is a movement to disrupt the
disruptors to redesign the Internet and
in so doing shake up existing
centralized incumbents throughout the
course we will introduce you to this
culture and its aspirations
this course is non technical in nature
it is an introductory course and thus
all terms will be explained it should be
accessible to anyone with a basic
understanding of web technologies and
economics
in this video we're going to give a
high-level overview
looking at the primary dimensions of
this technology that we call the
blockchain will first talk about the
underlining technology then the
distributed edges that this technology
supports then the token economies that
can be built on top of that ledger
system will only touch on these topics
here to get an overview before going
into them in more detail in future
videos on its most basic level the
blockchain is a new class of information
technology that combines cryptography
with distribute computing both of which
existed for a number of decades it was
the genius of Satoshi Nakamoto to
combine them in new ways to create a
model where a network of computers
collaborate towards maintaining a shared
and secure database as such we can say
the blockchain as the technology is
simply a distributed secure database
this database consists of a string of
blocks each one a record of data that
has been encrypted and given a unique
identifier called the hash mining
computers on the network validate
transactions add them to the block
they're building and then broadcast the
completed block to other nodes so that
all have a copy of the database because
there is no centralized component to
verify the alterations to the database
the blockchain depends upon a
distributed consensus algorithm in order
to make an entry onto the blockchain
database all the computers have to agree
about his state so that no one computer
can make an alteration without the
consensus of others once completed a
block goes into the blockchain as a
permanent record each time a block gets
completed a new one is generated there
is a countless number of such blocks in
the blockchain all connected to each
other by links in a chain in proper
linear chronological order the
blockchain was designed so that
transactions are
mutable meaning they cannot be deleted
each block contains a hash value that is
dependent upon the hash of the previous
block so they're all linked together
meaning if one is changed then all the
other blocks linked to it going forwards
will be altered this works to make the
data entered tamper proof what we've
described here is the workings of the
first generation of block chains which
function largely simply as databases but
the technology is currently evolving to
become much more than this as the second
generation already provides the capacity
to execute any computer code on the
blockchain the system is evolving to
become a globally distributed tile
computing infrastructure and as we'll
discuss in a future video it remains
very much a work in progress when seen
from this perspective blockchain
technology works to create a permanent
and secure database this makes
blockchain suitable for the storage of a
record or transaction that involves
value or in some way it needs to be a
secure and trusted source of information
these secure distributed records are
called distributed Ledger's a
distributed ledger is a consensus of
replicated shared and synchronized
digital data geographically dispersed
across multiple sites countries or
institutions without centralized
administration or centralized data
storage being maintained instead by a
distributed network of computers such
Ledger's can be used for any form of
asset registry such as inventory or
monetary transactions this might include
the recording of hard assets such as
physical property cars homes etc or
intangible assets such as currencies
patents votes identity healthcare data
or any other form of valuable
information
this distributed ledger technology
enables us to replace a multiplicity of
private databases within each
organization with one shared database
that is trusted and accessible by all
parties involved in this respect the
blockchain enables trust between parties
that may otherwise not trust each other
the results greatly strengthen our
capacity for collaboration between
organizations or between individuals
peer to peer without dependency on third
parties centralized institutions
likewise their results in transparency
and many other efficiencies this is of
major significance as we currently have
many centralized organizations that may
be internally optimized but the inter
organizational space in between them is
really inefficient with huge amounts of
border friction redundancy arbitrage and
resources wasted on competition by
enabling trusted into organizational
networks these Ledger's enable the
formation of organization and
collaboration where previously there was
none such as across whole supply chains
or for different healthcare providers to
collaborate around the patient's needs
or for different transport providers to
collaborate in delivering and integrated
logistics network
likewise second-generation blockchains
offer the possibility to automate the
workings of these networks through what
we call smart contracts smart contracts
are computer code that is stored inside
a blockchain which encode contractual
agreements these smart contracts are
self executing contracts with the terms
of the agreement or operation directly
written into lines of code which are
stored and executed on the blockchain
like normal computer programs these
containers hold algorithms that take an
input of data and depending on the value
of the input trigger certain events for
example this might be a financial
contract that takes as the input the
amounts of money in a person's accounts
if it is above a certain level then it
increases the interest rate that they
earn on their deposits such smart
contracts can be used for automating and
many basic operations on the network
once again working to remove the need
for intermediary third party
institutions as smart contracts can be
trusted a tamper-proof
and executes automatically
much of the current discussion
surrounding blockchain remains at the
level of the technology and the
possibilities of distributed edges as he
shared trusted database enabling the
collaboration between organizations with
the resulting disintermediation of
centralized institutions and market
exchanges however its implications go
far beyond this as the blockchain
concepts is more than just a database or
ledger it is a new organizing paradigm
for the discovery validation and
transfer of all discrete units of value
and the developments of distributed
organizations via token market systems a
token is a quantified unit of value that
is recorded on the blockchain this value
may be of any kinds it may be likes on
social media it might be a currency it
might be the integrity of an ecosystem
or might be an electrical units token
networks consists of a network of
independent nodes that act autonomously
but through incentive structures and the
signaling system of the market
self-organized to create emergent
coordination and thus a distributed
management system for example we might
create a clean air token where anyone
who provides a service that contra
buttes to the maintenance and provision
of clean air can earn tokens for example
by planting a tree while those who
pollutes by say operating a combustion
engine have to pay in air tokens thus
instead of having a centralized
Authority and a Clean Air Act's we have
a token market that works to create
signals that align people's incentives
with maintaining and growing the
underlining resource likewise the same
model could be applied to the management
of technology infrastructure as an
example we could think of traffic
control we currently have traffic
control systems in cities whose
operations are monitored by centralized
control centers but in a world of
autonomous vehicles and the blockchain
cars could signal to each other its
appear bidding tokens to see which gets
priority
in such a way the system has dynamically
allocated resources and self-organized
via distributed token networks in short
blockchain is not just an information
technology but also an institutional
technology in that it enables us to
design incentive structures in the form
of token economies and in such a way
converts centralized organizations into
distributed markets via token economics
this is where things start to get quite
complex as you move into the realm of
designing economies and incentive
systems for coordinating human activity
in a decentralized fashion something
that could potentially enable the
coordination of human activity at a much
larger scale than has been possible
before the great design innovation of
the blockchain is really its capacity to
coordinate a network of autonomous nodes
towards maintaining a shared
infrastructure and this is done not just
through innovations in information
technology but also through the design
of incentive systems which has
traditionally been the domain of
economics through adding a layer of
trust and value exchange to the Internet
the blockchain merges our newly
developed information networks with the
institutional structures that sit on top
of them in so doing it greatly
strengthens the capacity of those
networks as a new mode for organizing
society and economy by merging economics
and technology it enables us to redesign
institutional structures and ultimately
reconceptualize how we organize
virtually every aspect of society
economy and even technology
infrastructure based on networks of
autonomous nodes that are incentivized
to collaborate of course it does not do
this alone such claims can only be
realized in combination with other
technologies and broader processes of
change as such the blockchain has to be
understood in the context of a broader
set of technological transformations
taking place with the current evolution
of the internet most notably much
what the blockchain promises will only
be possible given parallel developments
in the Internet of Things data fication
and advanced analytics all of which are
combining to form the next generation of
Internet of which the blockchain will be
a critical infrastructure
in this video we're going to talk about
the basics of the blockchain as the
technology on its most basic level the
blockchain can be understood as a new
kind of database at least this was its
original design what's different about
this database is that it's distributed
digital databases have been around for a
while now but until recently they've
been designed to centralize information
on one computer or within one
organization the blockchain though uses
a distributed network of computers to
maintain a shared database the
blockchain is then a set of protocols
and encryption methods than enable a
network of computers to work together in
securely recording data within a shared
open database this database consists of
a series of encrypted blocks that
contain the data the blockchain is a
continuously growing list of these
blocks of data which are linked and
secured using cryptography this makes it
a trusted database with this trust being
maintained by open secure computer code
an encryption instead of any single
institution the database stores
information in blocks that are linked
together through hash values with
entries to this database being made by
computers that all have a copy of the
database and all must come to consensus
about its state before they can update
it so these are three central concepts
to understanding the system's workings
that of blocks and hashing mining and
proof of work and distributed consensus
we'll go over each of these separately
in terms of its structure a block chain
may be considered as a series of blocks
of data that are securely chained
together new blocks are formed as
participants create new data or wish to
update existing data these blocks are
encrypted and given a hash value that
represents a unique identifier of the
data within that block this hashing
works by a standard
algorithm being run over the blocks data
to compress it into a code which is
called the hash which is unique to that
documents no matter how large the file
or what information is contained it is
compressed into a 64 character secure
hash this hash value can be recalculated
from the underlining file confirming
that the original contents have not
changed but the reverse is not possible
given just the hash value you cannot
recreate the blocks data contained
within it which is encrypted all blocks
of data which are formed after the first
block are securely chained to the
previous one this means that the hash
value of the next block in the chain is
dependent upon the previous one thus
once recorded the data in any given
block cannot be altered afterwards
without the alteration of all subsequent
blocks as well as this hash pointer
linking to the previous block each block
typically contains as well a timestamp
so that we know what happened and when
it happens this hashing and linking of
blocks makes them inherently resistant
to the modification of their data making
them immutable records you can only
write data to the database and once it's
there it's very hard to change almost
impossible thus data is stored on the
blockchain is generally considered
incorruptible blockchain security
methods include the use of what we call
public key cryptography a public key
which is a long random looking string of
numbers is an address on the blockchain
value tokens sent across the network are
recorded as belonging to that address
a private key is like a password that
gives its owner
access to their digital assets or the
means to otherwise interact with the
corresponding data a public key is
associated with the private key so that
anyone can make an encrypted transaction
to the public key address but that
encrypted message can only be deciphered
with the private key that corresponds to
that public key in such a way effective
security only requires keeping the
private key privates
the public key can be openly distributed
without compromising security for
example on the Bitcoin blockchain to
receive funds from another person you
use a piece of software called the
wallets which creates a public key that
you give to someone else for them to
send bitcoins to that address with your
corresponding private key you can then
access that address with those bitcoins
on it
the blockchain is a distributed system
this means there is no centralized
organization to maintain and verify the
entries on the database this database is
instead maintained by a large number of
computers that are incentivized to
provide computing resources by earning
some form of tokens in exchange
but these computer nodes in the network
themselves cannot be trusted
individually
the city's required that the system
provide a mechanism for creating
consensus between scattered or
distributed parties that do not need to
trust each other but just need to trust
the mechanism by which their consensus
has been arrived down any computer that
is connected to the blockchain network
and using a client can perform the task
of validating and relaying transactions
each of these so-called minor computers
gets a copy of the blockchain which gets
downloaded automatically upon joining
the network when new entries into the
database are made these changes are
automatically broadcast across the
network mining nodes validate
transactions add them to the block their
building and then broadcast the state of
the complete block to other nodes on the
network in order to randomize the
processing of blocks across the nodes
and to avoid certain service abuses
block chains use various time stamping
schemas such as proof of work proof of
work describes a system that requires a
certain amount of resources or effort to
complete an activity typically this
resource is computing time as in the
case of the Bitcoin blockchain this is
realized on some form of challenge such
that no one actor on the network is able
to solve this challenge consistently
more than everyone else on the network
miners compete to add the next block in
the chain by racing to solve a very
difficult cryptographic puzzle the first
to solve the puzzle wins the lottery as
a reward for his or her efforts the
miner receives the small amounts of
newly minted bitcoins and a small
transaction fee it can sense this
algorithm like bitcoins proof-of-work
functions to ensure that the next block
in the blockchain is the one and only
version of the truth and it keeps
powerful adversaries from derating the
system block chains are trying to create
a secure trusted shared database and
do this through encryption and hashing
proof of work and network consensus the
hashing and linking of blocks makes it
difficult to go back and change a
previous block once it's entered but
this alone would not be suffice to
ensure that the data is truly tamper
proof so then the proof of work system
intentionally makes it computationally
more difficult to alter the database
thus making it extremely difficult to
alter all the blocks on top of this it
places that distributed consensus
mechanism so that even if someone did
manage to do this their record would not
match that of others and thus would not
be accepted as a valid record so to
successfully tamper with the block chain
you would need to alter all the blocks
on the chain redo the proof of work for
each block and take control of more than
50% of the peer-to-peer network only
then would your altar block become
accepted by everyone else on a block
chain of almost any size this would be
almost impossible to do indeed the
Bitcoin blockchain is very good proof of
this given that it now secures hundreds
of billions of dollars using this method
without the network having yet been
compromised at the end of the day what
this technology enables is a database
that is secured with automatic trusts
that is enabled by open source code and
encryption the data is tamper proof once
information is put into the database it
cannot be altered afterwards it is a
shared database as many people across a
network have a copy which is
continuously being updated so that all
have a single source of truth likewise
it is transparent meaning that everyone
can see all of the transactions and
alterations made to the database if
needed data quality and the resilience
of the network is maintained by massive
database replication across many
different nodes on the network no
centralized official copy exists and no
user is trusted more than any other
having started out life is simply a
mechanism to enable Bitcoin it has
become increasingly recognized that this
system is secure enough to work as a
ledger for the recording and exchange of
any value what we now call a
distribution there germ over the past
years blockchain evolving fast from the
original Bitcoin protocol to the second
generation aetherium platform to today
to where were in the process of building
the third generation of block chains in
this evolution we can see how the
technology is evolving from its original
form as essentially just a database to
becoming a fully fledged globally
distributed cloud computer in this video
we're going to trace the past present
and future of blockchain technology the
first blockchain was conceptualized in
2008 by an anonymous person or group
known as Toshi Nakamoto the concepts and
technicalities are described in an
accessible white paper termed Bitcoin a
peer-to-peer electronic cash system
these ideas were then first implemented
in 2009 as a core component supporting
Bitcoin where it served as the public
ledger for all transactions the
invention of the blockchain for Bitcoin
made it the first digital currency to
solve the double spending problem
without the need of a trusted Authority
or central server it was only later that
we came to really separate the concept
of the blockchain from that of its
specific implementation as a currency in
Bitcoin we came to see that the
underlining technology had a more
general application beyond digital
currencies in its capacity to function
as a distributed ledger tracking and
recording the exchange of any forms of
value the Bitcoin design has been the
inspiration for other applications and
has played an important role as a
relatively large scale proof-of-concept
within just a few years the second
generation of blockchains emerged
designed as a network on which
developers could build applications
essentially the beginning of its
evolution into a distributed virtual
computer this was made technically
possible by the development of the
etherium platform aetherium is an
open-source public blockchain based
distributed computer platform featuring
smart contract functionality it provided
a decentralized turing-complete virtual
machine which can execute computer
programs using a global network of nodes
aetherium was initially described in a
white paper by the italic Bertrand in
late 2013 with a goal of building
distributed applications the system went
live almost two years later and has been
very successful attracting a large and
dedicated community of developers
supporters and enterprises the important
contribution of etherium as the second
generation of blockchains
is that it worked to extend the capacity
of the technology from primarily being a
database supporting Bitcoin to becoming
more of a general platform for running
decentralized applications and smart
contracts both of which we'll discuss in
coming videos as of 2018 aetherium is
the largest and most popular platform
for building distributors applications
on many different types of applications
have been built an app from social
networks to identity systems to
prediction markets and many types of
financial applications aetherium has
been a major step board and with its
advent it has become ever more apparent
where we're heading with the technology
which is development of a global
distributed computer a massive globally
distributed cloud computing platform on
which we can run any application at the
scale and speed of today's major
websites with the assurance that it has
the security resilience and
trustworthiness of today's block chains
however the existing solutions that we
have are like extremely inefficient
Computers the existing blockchain
infrastructure is like a really bad
computer that is not able to do much
except proof of concepts getting to the
next level remains still a huge
challenge that involves some original
and difficult computer science game
theory and mathematical challenges
scalability remains at the hearts of the
current stage in the journey that were
on and this is what the third generation
of blockchain technologies are trying to
solve the mining required to support the
Bitcoin network currently consumes more
energy than many small nations being
equal to that of Denmark and costing
over 1.5 billion dollars a year in the
lectures deem a lot of this is being
fueled by cheap but dirty coal energy in
China where almost 60% of the mining is
currently being done this high energy
consumption is simply not scalable to
mass adoption etherium and Bitcoin use a
combination of technical tricks and
incentives to ensure that they
accurately record who owns what without
a centralized Authority the problem is
it's difficult to preserve this balance
was also growing the number of users
currently blockchain requires global
consensus on the order an outcome of all
transfers in aetherium all smart
contracts are stored publicly on every
node of the blockchain which has its
trade-offs the downside is that
performance issues arise in that every
node is calculating all the smart
contracts in real time which results in
those speeds this is clearly a
cumbersome task especially since the
total number of transactions is
increasing approximately every 10 to 12
seconds with each new block added the
volume of transactions is likewise an
existing constraint with cryptocurrency
speed is measured by TPS transaction per
second the Bitcoin network theoretical
maximum capacity is up to seven
transactions per second while the
ethereum blockchain as of 2018
can hand
about 15 transactions per seconds by
comparison a credit card network is
capable of handling more than 20
thousand transactions per seconds
equally Facebook may have about 900
thousand users on the site in any given
minutes meaning that its handling about
a hundred and seventy thousand requests
per second another issue is that of cost
the fact that it costs some small amount
to run the network so as to pay the
miners for maintaining the ledger what
we have is okay for a limited number of
large transactions such sending money
but making a small transaction by
purchasing a coffee could not be done by
most block chains they simply can't in
their existing form deal with a very
large amount of micro transactions such
as will be required to enable
high-volume machine-to-machine exchanges
it would prove too expensive to operate
these kind of economies that involve
many small exchanges but this is exactly
what many people will want to use the
blockchain for in the future
in response to these constraints a third
generation of blockchain networks are
currently under developments many
different organizations are currently
working on building this next-generation
blockchain infrastructure such projects
include Definity Neo Geo's iota and a
theorem itself they're each using
different approaches to try and overcome
existing constraints going into the
details of how these different networks
work is a bit advanced for this course
so we'll just give a brief overview to
two of them the Lightning Network is one
such project that seeks to extend the
capacities of existing block chains the
main idea is that small and non
significant transactions do not have to
be stored on the main blockchain this is
called an off chain approach because
small transactions happen off of the
main goal chain it works by creating
small communities where in transactions
can take place without each of those
transactions being registered on the
main blockchain a payment channel is
opened between a group of people with
the funds been frozen on the main
blockchain those members can then
transact between each other using their
private key to validate the transactions
this is a bit like having a tab or an
IOU with the shop where you just mark
down what you've exchanged so that you
don't have to update the main record in
the bank each time you make a purchase
the record stays local between the
members involved before at some time
setting the finances and updating the
main bank record this only requires two
transactions on the main blockchain one
to open the transaction channel and once
closed here all other transactions
happen just within the network without
it being registered on the main
blockchain this both reduces the
workload on the main blockchain and
makes it possible to run a very many
very small transactions within the sub
network as of the start of 2018 there is
a proof-of-concept running live on the
Bitcoin test net but the system will not
be fully operational until later in the
year as is the case with most of these
projects IATA is another example where
as existing block chains are sequential
chains where blocks are added in a
regular linear chronological order the
data structure of the iota system is
able to achieve high transactional
throughput by having parallel operations
the data structure is more like a
network rather than a linear chain
wherein processing and validation can
take place alongside each other the
other big difference is that there are
no specialized minors in this network
every node that uses the network
functions as a minor in the i/o to
network every node making a transaction
also actively participates in forming
the consensus that is to say everyone
does the mining this means that there is
no centralization of mining within the
network which is what creates
bottlenecks and demands lots of energy
likewise with this network there are no
transaction fees for validation and with
iota because it is more user generated
the more people that use the network the
faster becomes which is the opposite of
existing systems and obviously makes it
very scaleable there are lots of other
possible approaches to overcoming
existing constraints but suffice to say
the blockchain should be understood as
an emerging technology whose existing
implementation is like a large-scale
proof-of-concept running on a very
inefficient system but through lots of
experimentation and iteration well
hopefully in the coming years evolved
into this global distributed computer as
nan Lee Swan writes in her book first
there was the mainframe PC personal
computer paradigms and then the internet
revolutionized everything mobile and
social networking were the most recent
paradigm the current emerging paradigm
for this decade could be the connected
worlds of computing relying on
blockchain cryptography
to understand this better in the next
section we're going to talk about the
blockchain in the context of the broader
technological changes that are currently
underway as we build the next generation
of the Internet's what we call the
decentralized web or web 3.0 how we
understand the blockchain and where we
are with it today is extremely
transitory in this respect what we're
talking about in this course when we
talk about the blockchain is ready this
emerging IT infrastructure of a
distributed global cloud computer the
next generation of block chains will
take us a step further on that journey
what we called the blockchain today is
really just a very limited and often
very inefficient version of this we
still have many very difficult problems
to solve before we'll get there possibly
that end stage will look something like
the blockchain of today but possibly it
would look very different
people will make big claims about the
potential of the blockchain to
revolutionize the foundations of social
and economic organization but the
blockchain can only have such potential
as part of a broader ecosystem of
technologies that are emerging as the
next generation of the Internet's what
may be called web 3.0 or the
decentralized web today powerful
technological changes are coalescing to
take us into a new technology paradigm
these include the rise of advanced
analytics coupled with data fication and
the Internet of Things the blockchain
will have to work synergistically with
these if it's true capacities are to be
realized but to understand this next
generation web we need to understand a
bit about the history of the Internet
going back to the early 90s web 1.0 was
the first generation of the world wide
web it was based primarily on the
technology of HTTP which worked to link
documents on different computers and
make them accessible over the Internet
HTML was then used to display these
documents so that any connected computer
with a browser could access and read a
web page this first iteration of the web
was all about information as it enabled
us to exchange information much more
efficiently and head Sagat the name
information superhighway even though it
was a revolution in information exchange
content creators were few with the vast
majority of users simply acting as
consumers of contents it was really very
static and lacked interactivity whereas
in the web 1.0 era people were limited
to pass a viewing of contents with web
2.0 websites allowed users to interact
collaborates and become the creators of
contents with web 2 people could not
only read from the web but also write to
it and thus it got the nickname the
readwrite web by the early 2000s
new server-side scripting technologies
such as PHP enabled developers to easily
build applications where people could
write information to a database with
that information then being dynamically
updated every time they refresh the page
almost all of the websites that dominate
the web today are based on this
server-side scripting technology it gave
the social networking blogging video
sharing obey YouTube Facebook and all
the other large platforms the most
people spend most of their internet time
using the idea of web 3.0 has been
around for a while but it's only very
recently with the development of the
blockchain that it is actually starts to
become something real web 2.0 has
evolved to become highly centralized
around very large platforms running out
of ever larger data centers creating
many issues surrounding security privacy
control and concentration of power in
the hands of large enterprises it's only
today that these issues are starting to
enter into mainstream discourse web 3 is
set to disrupt this whole technology
paradigm as the critical change that is
coming about is the word D centralizing
the web the blockchain provides the
protocols and cryptography for a
globally distributed network of
computers to collaborate on maintaining
a public secure database and with a
virtual machine like aetherium we can
run code on this creating a new set of
distributed applications these new
technologies of the blockchain ipfs and
the distributed web enabled us to
reconfigure the internet into a
distributed global computer so that
we're no longer dependent upon the web
platforms and data centers of web 2.0 to
run the internet but now can build and
run applications on this shared global
computing infrastructure as might be
polled of the Institute for the future
noted it starts with the realization
that the internet that we know today is
only one possible interpretation of the
original vision
of an open clear to peer network
independent of any centralized
technology commercial entity or
sovereign governments think of it as a
first curved internet one that is
increasingly vulnerable to abuse and
even collapse to date we've largely
taken the infrastructure of the internet
for grants it's all of the innovation
and action has been focused on the
application layer that sits on top of it
on web applications like social
networking or e-commerce with the
developments of blockchain and
particularly with this third generation
we're starting to innovate on the low
level protocols asking not if we can
build a better web application but if we
can build a better internet the
implications of the decentralized web
are indeed radical in that it enables us
to create automated services
disintermediate existing incumbents and
enable people to set up their own secure
networks of exchange empowering them in
new ways the blockchain will be a core
part of web 3.0 but the next-generation
internet would also see the convergence
of the Internet of Things and big data
analytics the ongoing fundamental
process of data fication will be a key
aspect to this next-generation Internet
as we increase in the instrument our
world's data will flow from all sources
about everything data fication is the
term given to our newly found ability to
captures data many aspects of the world
in our lives that have never been
quantified before this process results
in what we call big data vast amounts of
unstructured data that can be mined by
advanced analytical methods to gain new
insight into the world around us this is
important with respect to the blockchain
because firstly it means we'll have a
lot of sensitive data that we want to
store secondly we will be quantifying
accounting for and exchanging all sorts
of value that we did not or could not in
the past thirdly such a diversity of
sources of data
combined with advanced analytics which
could find cross correlations and
patterns within it can provide a new
source to verify the data that is being
inputted to the blockchain without
depending on a centralized Authority for
validation the next-generation internet
will be much smarter
whereas web 1 was dumb and web 2 was
dynamic web 3 will incorporate various
aspects of machine learning and
cognitive computing as a service as it
becomes infused into almost all
applications making the web truly
adaptive responsive and personalized
whereas web 1 and web 2 were largely
about people exchanging information in
web 3 machines will come online and the
internet will become something much more
physical as billions of devices and
actuators connected to all sorts of
things from tractors to watches to
factories and drones enabling them to
interact and coordinate machine to
machine the value of the Internet of
Things IOT will not be in making one
device or system smart it will be in
enabling seamless processes across
systems
this will require open networks that can
communicate and coordinate components on
demand across domains organizations and
systems the envision of IOT is not to
have our lives populated with thousands
of smart things but instead to change
our world from discrete things to
service processes to do this these
technologies will have to communicate
securely it appear dynamically
allocating resources and this will
require some kind of distributed secure
infrastructure like the blockchain and
likewise micro economies this ties in
with the broader process of change which
comes about as we move into a services
economy called services ation which is
the shift from products and the
ownership of things to the access of
services on demands for example instead
of only a car you simply have access to
a car sharing service
this economy of temporary usage VA
services requires the formation of
frictionless markets and automated
exchanges that the blockchain is
well-suited to support as we'll discuss
in a future video these components of
the next generation internet the
blockchain the Internet of Things and
advanced analytics are each of them very
powerful technologies that will have a
profound effect on society they will
take us much further into this new
worlds of the information age as power
shifts in a radical way from people in
hierarchical institutions to automated
networks and the algorithms that
coordinate them in the coming decades
more and more of our systems of
organization will move to the Internet
and it will become vastly more complex
than today in web-one and web 2 we
develop the internet from small to large
through a client-server architecture the
work decentralized the web around large
data centers but the internet after data
fication and all these IOT devices have
come online will not be large it will be
more like infinite you can get from
small to large by centralizing but you
get from large to infinity through
distributing and that's what the
blockchain can do for this next
generation Internet
technologies are just tools that enable
us to do things the interesting part of
the blockchain is really what it enables
in terms of new forms of distributed
organization as one commentator noted
the blockchain is an institutional
technology not an information technology
there's an enormous difference between
the two institutional revolutions are
things that don't happen very often
blockchain technology enables new forms
of network distributes to organizations
something that runs very much contrary
to our existing organizational paradigm
and that's what makes it somewhat
difficult for us to understand the
organizational model of the Industrial
Age that we inherit today was one of
centralization in order to achieve
economies of scale through mass
production thus reducing unit cost and
providing for a mass society the
technologies of the Industrial Age
selectively favored centralization of
production within closed hierarchical
organizations manufacturing is in
centralized factories transport systems
are centralized around transport hubs
education within schools and
universities entertainment centralized
within mass media organizations and
governance centralized within state-run
organizations and so on the information
revolution is in the process of taking
us into a new world of distributed
networks as the organizational paradigm
of the Information Age the combination
of telecommunications networks and
computerized coordination enables us to
replace centralized management with
enclosed hierarchies with open networks
as the underlining technology matures
were able to convert more and more
systems that were previously closed and
centralized and have them managed
through automated networks and the
blockchain is just one more stage in
this process we saw this with the rise
of the online platforms like eBay uber
or Alibaba social networks blogging etc
that built massive networks of uses
exchanging goods and
services but these platforms were still
dependent upon the centralized
organization to manage the shared
database for the computing
infrastructure for the algorithms for
financial transactions and to enable
trust and authentication in the network
the decentralized web takes these
platforms a step further by offering a
shared open and secure database that can
be trusted by all parties and a set of
protocols for the secure exchange of
value between organizations and
individuals peer-to-peer the web
platforms are open networks this means
they do not just optimize within a given
organization but can enable coordination
across whole industries indeed this is
why and how they're quickly supplanting
the closed organizations what
centralized organizations enabled was
trust cooperation and coordination
within organizations but what the
blockchain enables is trust coordination
and cooperation between organizations
and between individuals if we look at
how our society and economy is currently
organized
we'll see many closed organizations that
are internally optimized but when we
look at the inter organizational space
it's extremely inefficient along many
dimensions if we look at the way
businesses coordinate along a supply
chain or the way nation-states
interoperate in the global political
system we will see there is huge
redundancy and friction caused by
discontinuities a classical example of
this is the border system between
nation-states and the bureaucratic
procedures for obtaining a visa for
moving from one nation to another which
creates a massive amount of friction at
the inter organizational space and it's
because those organizations don't have
an effective into organizational
infrastructure for collaboration and
coordination this greatly reduces the
overall effectiveness of these systems
and the delivered outcome for the end
user when we look internal to these
organizations they look like efficient
well-oiled machines but when we look
between them the whole space is very
inefficient
the whole space is very ineffective at
delivering overall outcomes and this is
part of the significance of the
blockchain because it provides a shared
trusted database between organizations
it has the potential to switch to
dynamics within economy and society from
competition between close centralized
organizations to collaboration between
organizations and greatly strengthened
working capacities across organizational
boundaries the results of this would be
much more efficient overall societal and
economic outcomes indeed we can note
that achieving coordination across
organizations could result in quantum
leaps in delivering outcomes and our
capacity to tackle major global
challenges of today such as
environmental degradation where weak
existing into organizational
institutional infrastructure has gained
little traction in this respects the
blockchain has the potential to give us
not just incremental improvements but an
order of magnitude greater capacities
within society through collaboration
within whole ecosystems it is precisely
this coordination across organizations
industries nations and people that is
required to provide the resources needed
to tackle some of today's most complex
challenges and it's precisely this that
is significantly absent within existing
institutional structures because of the
centralizing forces prevalent within the
industrial age we live in societies that
are operated by many different closed
organizations many different companies
all producing cars and competing for
market share many different governments
that all focus on the interests of their
citizens over those of others many
different health care providers
transport providers at cetera
the results of this is though a huge
amount of inefficiency in redundancy
when taken as a whole many different
companies all recreating the wheel
within their own organizations and
expending huge amounts of time and
energy on trying to get ahead of their
peers
we assume that this is the normal state
of operations that it's just human
nature in some way but in fact it's
really just a function of the
institutional structures we have built
over the past centuries as game theory
will tell us people respond to the
incentives and the socio-economic forces
acting on them in the absence of
cooperative structures competition is
often the optimal strategy for
individuals and organizations but once
there is the institutional structures to
enable trust and coordination between
members cooperation can become a much
more viable strategy for the agents
involved because the blockchain enables
this shared and trusted database that
doesn't belong to any single
organization it makes it greatly more
possible and viable for organizations to
collaborate on a single solution or
single source and achieve much better
results for each organization and the
economy as a whole as an example of this
cooperation across different closed
organizations we could think about the
design and construction of a building
there may be many different companies
involved in this process or creating
their own designs and diagrams for the
building with each having to
continuously contact each other to
access exchange and cross-reference all
this information given a single shared
database they could though or
collaborate on a single design of the
building making for a greatly more
efficient overall process while at the
same time each organization would
benefit and thus the overall results are
more efficient likewise the same is true
for identity we currently have many
different copies of our identity spread
across many different organizations
governments social networks employees
etc but each of these only has a partial
understanding of us currently we're
recreating the will for each
organization while data and reputation
does not move well between them instead
a single identity could be created on
the blockchain that belongs to the
individual with each organization then
contributing to this data as they work
together to create
a more complete record of identity and
reputation in so doing we've moved from
all those frictions between these closed
organizations to collaboration and
synergies between them creating
something that is greater than any of
the parts they had before the same for a
supply chain instead of each participant
holding their own documents and records
during each stage in supply chain a
single record for the item could be
created on the blockchain with each
organization then contributing their
information to it to create a single
source of truth that is accessible to
always need it while at the same time
being more secure than having separate
records in each centralized database the
end results of this new institutional
technology is a much greater capacity
for inter organizational collaboration
and powerful ecosystems that are greater
than the sum of their parts given that
all our current systems of organization
that are centralized could be
decentralized in this fashion using
blockchain technology we can see how it
really could enable every organization
of society and economy organizations
within society rarely operate in
isolation they function as parts of
ecosystems and the value for society is
not created by anyone but instead by the
flow of value across the ecosystem it's
not Apple that delivers our iPhones
it's a massive global supply chain of
hundreds of different organizations
collaborating whereas our previous
institutional structures optimized for
individual organizations the blockchain
optimizes for the value within the whole
ecosystem and thus potentially a much
greater value for society as a whole the
information revolution is changing the
world from disconnected to connected the
genie of hyper-connectivity is out of
the bottle and connectivity along
virtually all dimensions is
proliferating daily as a consequence our
systems of organization will change from
being based around fixed structures and
boundaries to being coordinated via
connections
instead of the controller components
through fixed higher
structures organization would emerge out
the interaction and the exchange of
value along those interactions enabling
that will require a massive build-out of
secure frictionless information networks
this global cloud computer of blockchain
to understand better how this shared
database that enables inter
organizational collaboration works we'll
talk about distributed ledger technology
as we've been talking about the
blockchain is like another layer to the
Internet that enables secure trusted
records and transactions between people
who may not otherwise trust each other
the trust is in the technology computer
code in mathematics rather than people
and centralized institutions in this
respect people sometimes talk about the
blockchain as a trust machine in its
capacity to enable a network where Trust
is created by design it's built into the
system automatically because the
blockchain creates a trusted database it
can function as a record of value
storage in exchange these records of
value and transactions may be called
Ledger's since ancient times
Ledger's have formed the backbone to our
economies to record contracts and
payments for the buying and selling of
goods or the exchange of assets like
property these ledges started out as
records in stone clay tablets and
papyrus and later paper as they evolved
into the ledger books supporting modern
accounting these Ledger's enabled the
formation of currencies trade lending
and the evolution of banking
over the last couple of decades though
these records have moved into the
digital realm as whole rooms of people
working to maintain accounts have been
replaced by digital computers which have
made possible the complex global
economic system we live in today this
record-keeping system is once again
being revolutionized as these Ledger's
are shifting to a global network of
computers which is cryptographically
secure fast and decentralized what we
call distributed ledger or distributed
ledger technology DLT for shorts a
distributed ledger can be described as a
ledger of any transactions or records
supported by a decentralized network
from across different locations and
people eliminating the need of a
centralized Authority
all the information on ledger is
securely and accurately stored using
cryptography and can be accessed using
keys and cryptographic signatures any
changes or additions made to ledger are
reflected and copied to all participants
in a matter of seconds or minutes the
participants at each node of the network
can access the recording shared across
the network and can own an identical
copy of it at the same time these
networks make constantly available for
examination a full audit trail of the
information history which can be traced
back to the moment when a piece of
information was created and every
participant in the network can get
simultaneous access to a common few of
the information these Ledger's can be
used for the recording tracking
monitoring and transacting of all forms
of assets all asset registries
inventories and exchanges including
every area of economics finance and
currencies physical assets such as cars
and houses and intangible assets such as
votes ideas health data reputation etc
in this case the blockchain can serve as
a public record repository for whole
societies including the registration of
all documents events identity and assets
in this system all property could become
smart property this is the notion of
encoding every assets of the blockchain
with the unique identifier such that the
asset can be tracked controlled and
exchanged on the blockchain for example
distributed edges could be used to
replace or supplement all existing
intellectual property management systems
as they can register the exact content
of any digital asset such as a file
image health record or code to the
ledger and give it a unique identifier
in the form of the hash values that we
discussed earlier there are two main
classes of distributed ledger public
Ledger's and permission Ledger's
the former type is maintained by public
nodes and is accessible to anyone
Bitcoin is a well-known example of a
public blockchain where anyone can read
the chain anyone can make legitimate
changes and anyone can write a new block
into the chain ripple is an example of a
permission blockchain where the creators
of the network determine who may act as
transaction validators on that network
distributed ledger platforms in each
category have their own unique features
some are designed for specific types of
application and others for more general
use for instance in the quarter DLC
platform which is a consortium of more
than 70 of the world's largest financial
institutions the sharing of individual
ledger data is limited to parties with
the legitimate need to know which is not
the case for public platforms DLT
technology can have a powerful
disintermediation effect as data can be
put directly onto the shared database by
the nodes in the network there is no
longer need for a centralized
organization to provide this service a
developer can create a DLT on a
blockchain and use public/private key
cryptography to give people secure
storage space on that ledger allowing
people to own their own data which
creates a very different scenario to the
world we live in today
currently centralized organizations like
Google and Facebook suck up all of the
little bits of data we need behind us
and use it to serve us customized
advertisements from which they create
their revenue this results in a huge
power imbalance within society where
centralized organizations armed with
teams of mathematicians and computer
scientists use mountains of data to
influence people's behavior towards
purchasing with products of their
appetizers data that is a very valuable
asset and the information society and of
critical importance to tackling major
societal challenges is being used
against us in many ways creating a
stumbling
the societies are becoming increasingly
aware of in a world of distributed edges
people have their own little databases
on the blockchain and can own their own
data giving it to organizations to use
when and where needed
fundamentally reversing the current
dynamic and truly empowering individuals
your health records reside in your
health ledger and different health care
providers can access and update that
single record but only with the
permission of the end-user as the data
remains theirs and they choose who can
have access to it likewise when people
own their own data on a distributed
their germ they can transact directly
its appear as is the case with Bitcoin
with the existing traditional system
when you pay for a ride in a taxi with a
credit card it looks like you're paying
the driver directly when in fact what is
happening is that a database record
belonging to my bank is being debited
and a database belonged to the bank of
the company that the driver works for is
being credited in this respect we can
note that in our society value and data
do not really belong to individuals all
the time they're being held behind the
walls of some centralized organization
and we are dependent upon them to secure
and validate it's creating huge power
imbalances within society in contrast
with the Bitcoin blockchain the
individual has a ledger record and a
secure key with which they can access
their records when they send money they
send it directly to the other person's
record it simply gets debited from your
record and added to theirs directly
peer-to-peer no centralized organization
holds that data distributed ledger
technology can greatly improve
transparency reduce corruption and
improve security while reducing overhead
costs of auditing accounting and legal
issues currently records of value are
hidden within the databases of
centralized organizations where they're
largely in excess
for their many possible uses within
other systems they are open to
manipulation by members within those
organizations which breeds corruption
and because of that there has to be all
sorts of regulation and legal
requirements that create many overhead
costs and it's this they are centralized
points of failure for critical data
sources as large concentrations of
valued data proved very attractive for
malicious actors likewise it is
inefficient to be constantly updating
and synchronizing data across many
centralized databases by putting the
information on a shared ledger it can be
easily made accessible and visible on
demand as needed
because there is tamper proof we can
remove many existing points of
corruption and the associated need for
regulation likewise it is made secure by
distributed networks without a single
point of failure and continuously
synchronized across all nodes to create
a single source of truth for all users
one of the key technology innovations of
second-generation blockchains
has been the development of what are
called smart contracts smart contracts
are computer code that is stored inside
of a blockchain which encode contractual
agreements smart contracts are self
executing with the terms of the
agreement or operation directly written
in two lines of code stored and executed
on the blockchain computer a contract in
the traditional sense is a binding
agreement between two or more parties
to do or not do something each party
must trust the other parties to fill
their side of the obligation they are a
written or spoken agreement that is
intended to be enforced by law a
multiplicity of different contractual
agreements form the institutional
foundations to our modern society and
economy which have evolved since ancient
times if we think about something as
seemingly simple as a cafe serving a cup
of coffee we will see that this process
is really enabled by a massive amount of
contractual agreements between different
parties that enable them to cooperate in
delivering that outcome contracts
between employees and employer of the
coffee shop contracts that provide
workers with health coverage contracts
that ensure the coffee-shop contracts
between suppliers along the supply chain
contracts between property owner and
tenant etc our economies are powered by
a massively complex set of contractual
agreements that are currently created
and enforced by centralized
organizations like insurance companies
and banks which themselves are supported
by the ultimate centralized authority in
the system
the nation-states institutions are
societies and economies almost
completely dependent upon third party
organizations to maintain and enforce
those contractual agreements smart
contracts feature these same kind of
agreements to act or not act
but they removed the need for the
trusted third party between members
involved in the contracts this is
because a smart contract is both defined
by the computer code and executed or
enforced by the code itself
automatically without discretion at such
blockchains as smart contract technology
can remove the reliance on centralized
systems and enable people to create
their own contractual agreements that
can be automatically enforced and
executed by the computer code these
smart contracts are decentralized in
that they do not subsist on a single
centralized server but are distributed
and self executing across a network of
nodes
this means that untrusted parties can
transact with each other in a much more
fluid fashion without depending upon
third parties to initiate and maintain
the rules of the transaction likewise
smart contracts enable autonomy between
members meaning that after it is
launched and running a contract in its
initiating agents need not be in further
contacts one illustration of this
concept is offending machine unlike a
person a vending machine operates
algorithmically you provide the source
input of money and product selection
which the machine takes as input and
simply execute on a rule automatically
to produce the pre-specified output the
same instruction set will be followed
every time in every case when you
deposit money and make a selection the
item is released there is no possibility
of the machine not wanting to or not
feeling like complying with the contract
or only partially complying as long as
it's functional there's another example
we can think about a situation where
four people pool their money to make a
joint investment that will return
interests of them a smart contract could
be programmed on the blockchain to take
any interest that is created divided
into four and sent each amount to the
corresponding wallets of the different
stakeholders
a smart contract is then ready just an
Accounts on the blockchain that is
controlled by code instead of by user
because it's on the blockchain it is
immutable that means the code cannot be
changed and thus all participants in
this investment can be assured that they
will get their fair share automatically
the code dictates how the process will
take place and no individual has the
power to change it no individual no
organization no government can censor
alter or manipulate the contracts in
this respect it's often said that code
is law in the sense that the code will
execute no matter what of course
computer code has been for a while now
acting as the law for example as
services have gone online we're
increasingly faced with web forms that
strictly control what inputs are allowed
if you want to buy an item on iTunes USA
then you'll have to have a credit card
with the US address the system will also
enforce this by not letting you complete
the purchase with an incorrect address
as another example a logistics company
could use smart contracts to execute
code that says if I receive cash on
delivery at this location then trigger a
supplier request to stock a new item
since the existing item was just
delivered
a combination of smart contracts with
blockchain encoded property gives us the
idea of smart property smart property is
simply property whose ownership is
controlled via blockchain encoded
contractual agreements for example a
pre-established
smart contract could automatically
transfer the ownership of a vehicle
title from the holding company to the
individual owner when all the loan
installments have been cleared the key
idea of smart property is controlling
ownership and access to an asset by
having it registered as a digital asset
on the ledger and connecting that to a
smart contract in some cases physical
world hard assets could quite literally
be controlled via the blockchain one
example of such an IOT blockchain system
is SLOC it a door lock that is connected
to a smart contract on the blockchain
which controls when and who can open the
lock this enables anyone to rent sell or
share their property without need of a
middleman with such innovations parking
spots can be subletted on-demand
Airbnb accommodation could become fully
automated or someone with twenty bikes
in Bangladesh could rent them out with
smart contract locks the bike could shut
itself off if it is not been paid for or
if it's stolen then there could be an
automatic deposit system or likewise if
the person wanted they could simply pay
a certain price to purchase the bike at
any time
like all algorithms smart contracts
require input values and only act if
certain predefined conditions are met
when a particular value is reached the
smart contract changes its state and
executes that programmatically
predefined algorithms automatically
triggering an event on the blockchain
thus the workings of the overall
contracts can only be as good as the
inputted data if both data is imported
to the system then false results will be
outputted blockchains
cannot access data outside of their
network
thus requires some form of trusted data
feed as input to the system what may be
called an Oracle an Oracle is a data
feed provided by an external service and
designed for use in smart contracts on
the blockchain Oracle's
provide external data and trigger smart
contract executions
when predefined conditions are met such
conditions could be any data like
weather temperature the quantity of
items in stock the completion of a
successful payments changes in the
prices on the stock market etc an Oracle
in the context of block chains and smart
contracts is then an agent the finds and
verifies real-world occurrences and
provides this information to a
blockchain to be used by smart contracts
Oracle's are third-party services which
are not part of the blockchain consensus
mechanism thus whether it be a news feed
website or a sensor the source of
information needs to be trustworthy as
an example we could think of an online
betting platform based on the blockchain
that uses smart contracts to
automatically execute payouts to people
who have placed bets on sports matches
the smart contract system would then
have to be connected to a trusted Oracle
to provide it with the score of the
matches as of present this Oracle would
likely have to be associated with some
trusted third party centralized
organization like a sports channel or
Bloomberg for stock prices however in
the future through data fication an IOT
pervasive sensing this might also be
automated given the use of advanced
analytics using automated Oracle's that
draw data from a myriad of sources and
complex analytics to find cross
correlations that provide a statistical
assurance that for example a given event
occurred or did not occur the advantages
of smart contracts are numerous firstly
they are automatic which could remove
the
time and costs associated with managing
and enforcing them making them more
efficient as they can be cheaper and
faster to run through this form of
automation a much greater amount of
exchange could take place that otherwise
would have never happens in such a way
we can see how distributive edges and
smart contracts are key parts in
enabling a true services economy where
ownership is displaced by temporal usage
through the on-demand provisioning of
services secondly they could reduce
corruption as code is both transparent
in its workings and automatically
executed this leaves the room for
individuals or organizations to alter it
to their advantage thirdly they can
reduce dependency upon centralized
organizations that people may be able to
set up their own contractual agreements
peer to peer thus limiting the arbitrary
power of centralized organizations
lastly they can also deliver certainty
as smart contracts guarantee a very
specific set of outcomes that are
predetermined before hands enabling all
parties know exactly what will happen
but herein also lies some of their
limitations by automating the execution
of a contract they are dependent upon
formal rules with well specified inputs
and leave little room for a multiplicity
of eventualities where the rules may
need to be slightly altered because of
unforeseen circumstances for example a
car that's being used on demand that
operates through a smart contract may
simply shut the user out if they have
not paid their bill and would take
little accounts of the facts but it may
be a life-or-death emergency usage in
the real world many unpredictable and
unforeseen events to occur and rules
sometimes need to be flexible and adapt
Sporto accommodates and this is one
advantage of having human oversight as
people are much more capable at judging
such circumstances and responding
appropriately to complex unforeseen
eventualities so the degree to which we
can automate contracts is relative
the kind of environment that is being
operated in and in more complex
situations they will often need to be
some form of governing body to intervene
when needed and this creates new
complications surrounding governance
that are still yet to be figured out the
advent of the etherion platform in 2015
has worked to provide a virtual
computing infrastructure for running
applications on the blockchain this new
form of program is called a distributed
application or DAP for short aetherium
was the first developer platform for
building distributed applications it was
a foundational general-purpose
blockchain based platform that is a
turing-complete virtual machine meaning
that it can run any computer code
although etherium was the first and
still the largest platform for building
distributed applications there are now
others such as block stack oreos all of
which provided the underlining
infrastructure for building DAB's
our working definition of a DAP is an
application that runs on a network in a
distributed fashion with participant
information securely protected and
operations executed in a decentralized
fashion across a network of nodes taps
use open source code operate
autonomously with data and records
cryptographically stored on a blockchain
on a technical level a tab is very much
similar to a normal web application
except unlike with the normal web app
where the back-end code is running on a
centralized server a dab has its code
running on a distributed peer-to-peer
network a tap can have front-end code
and user interfaces written in any
language just like a normal app as such
taps will often look and feel very much
like regular apps and people will soon
be using them in the coming decade
without even realizing him like all apps
perform specific functions whereas
bitcoin is the decentralized value
exchange a decentralized application
aims to achieve functionality beyond
transactions the middie exchange value
many types of decentralized apps are
starting to emerge as the underlining
technology continues to progress already
we can see many tabs represent
alternatives to the existing popular web
applications probably the most
successful DAP to date is steam it steam
it is a blogging and social networking
websites on top of the steam it
blockchain database
the general concept is very similar to
other blogging websites or social news
sites like Reddit but the text content
is saved in a blockchain using a
blockchain enables rewarding comments
and posts with secure tokens value in
this way users can earn currencies for
their posts and comments likewise for
existing marketplace applications like
eBay and Craigslist we have the
decentralized version open Bazaar open
Bazaar is an open source project
developing a protocol for e-commerce
transactions in a fully decentralized
marketplace because the application
connects people directly via peer to
peer network it cost nothing to download
and use it unlike sites like eBay or
Amazon there are no fees to list items
and no fees when an item is sold open
Bazaar is not a company like eBay but an
open source projects each user
contribution etwork equally and is in
control of their own storage and private
data
another example is Storch which is the
decentralized cloud storage application
similar to job box storage is based on
blockchain technology and peer-to-peer
protocols to provide secure private and
a-fishing cloud storage system the
application incentivizes storage
providers and connects them with those
who require it each file saved on the
application is free
encrypted and spread across the network
until you're ready to use it again the
keys to the database remain with the
owners meaning the data is not
accessible by a centralized cloud
provider there are many other examples
of DAPs but the general concepts can be
applied to any area that requires secure
records and benefits from
decentralization these applications are
automated which means they can operate
at very low or even zero cost because of
their snaps may be used to disrupt the
existing platform economy as whole
platforms like uber or Airbnb may
eventually be converted into dabs that
run automatically without the need for
the centralized platform the advantages
of dabs is that they're fully automated
have superior fault tolerance and
trustless execution these decentralized
apps potentially represent the next
generation of computing because the
blockchain is a secure system that
enables a trusted network it's often
described as a value exchange protocol
in this respect people often say that
what the web did for the exchange of
information the blockchain will do for
the exchange of value just as the web
revolutionized the use an exchange of
information within society disrupting
whole industries based upon the
centralization of information so to the
blockchain is set to do the same for the
recording and exchanging of all forms of
quantifiable value this idea of value
lies at the hearts of the blockchain if
there is no value involved in the
process then there is no need for trust
and no need to use the blockchain the
vision of the internet of value is for
any quantum of value to be exchanged as
quickly and as fluidly as multimedia is
today on the web
although multimedia can move around the
world almost instantaneously a single
payment from one country to another is
slow expensive and unreliable
often taking days and involving numerous
intermediary third parties to validate
and process transactions at a
significant cost
thus it is no accident that the first
widespread use of the blockchain was for
currencies because it is the most
immediate and obvious source for
quantified value within society however
to truly understand the revolutionary
potential of this technology is to
appreciate how value and its exchange
influences and regulates almost all
aspects of human affairs as a
consequence the control of how value
gets defined measured and exchanged is
the key source of power and control
within society and has been since the
origins civilization today value of
almost any kind is defined quantified
and regulated by centralized
organizations whether this is a national
government creating their own currency
or one's role within a hierarchy
defining one's economic status or the
branded clothing that we wear to signal
to others our social status and value in
society however the move into the
networked society shifts the locus of
organization from closed institutions to
individuals and networks but off chain
technology is a key element enabling
this process by creating a shared ledger
where people can own their own data it
also enables a shift in the locus of
value within economy to the individual
in networks in a world of limited
connectivity limited transparency
unlimited peer-to-peer trust it was
necessary to have third party
institutions to define quantify and
authenticate sources of value within
society and economy but in a world of
pervasive peer-to-peer connectivity
transparency and trusted low cost
automated networks value can be defined
through a negotiation between peers
within distributed networks
the rise of digital currencies about one
such example of this the surprising
thing for a lot of people is that most
major currencies like the dollar yen and
euro aren't backed by anything they're
just pieces of metal paper and entries
in a bank account that get their value
from everyone simply believing that they
have value and accepting them as a
medium of exchange and that's all it's
really necessary
currencies and money work a little bit
like languages they are subject to
network effects to give them value the
more people who agree to and understand
the language the more valuable that that
specific language has as a form of
communications dollars remnant B euros
and bitcoins have no intrinsic value
they're all social protocols and they
merely represent a way of supporting the
value flows between individuals in the
past because of low levels have trusted
here connectivity we required
centralized institutions like
governments and banks to get these value
exchange networks started to support
them regulate them and maintain them and
this gave those organizations a lot of
power this is a critical aspect that the
internet and the blockchain are changing
the blockchain enables us to create
trusted and automated peer networks of
exchange which greatly strengthens the
capacities of people to negotiate and
define value via direct here to peer
exchanges people can now set up their
own currencies with the value of the
currency depending simply on what others
are willing to pay for it Veeran
automated peer-to-peer network exchange
but the internet of value is more than
just currencies because value is of
course a much broader concept than just
pure economic utility in talking about
the internet of value it's important to
recognize that on a societal level were
moving into a post-industrial services
economy the traditional conception of
what society values is being revisited
as a new set of societal and
environmental factors re-enter the
equation people are less and less
content with the traditional concept of
GDP as the sole metric for how well
they're doing and more and more
demanding actual quality of life which
of course engenders a broader spectrum
of values beyond economic utility over
the past decades we've increasingly
begun the process of tracking and
accounting for different forms of value
whether this is green bonds social
impact bonds company loyalty schemes
carbon accounting or a multiplicity of
other forms but simply the erosion and
loss of social and environmental capital
that occurred during the Industrial Age
is generating a recognition and growing
awareness to their value metrics for how
well a society is doing increasingly
take account of many more environmental
and social parameters in combination
with GDP along with this recognition to
the importance of different forms of
value comes also the technical means the
quantify an exchange them through the
process of data fication information
technology lets us measure track and
exchange evermore types of value at ever
smaller increments likes on Facebook
people's attention carbon emissions etc
with the rise of big data and IOT will
be quantifying an ascribed value to
almost everything and the blockchain
will provide the network infrastructure
for tracking and exchanging all these
micro and macro quanta of value this
shift from the narrow form of economic
value that dominated in the Industrial
Age to a broader spectrum of values that
emerges within a post-industrial society
is enabled by the
Tribute alleges system that supports
what we call token economies wherein we
can define a token as a measure of any
form of value and then built an economy
around that token economies and the
internet of value built upon the current
expansion of digital markets brought
about by the rise of the platform
economy over the past decades with web
2.0 we've begun the process of expanding
markets to more and more spheres of life
that were previously organized via
centralized coordination after only ten
years or so of this process the biggest
accommodation service in the worlds is
no longer a centralized organization
like the Hilton it's now an online
market the same is true for the taxi
industry the same is true for commerce
with 10 million merchants and 440
million active users the Alibaba network
is now reported as the largest retailer
in the worlds after just 19 years of
existence markets are complex they
typically require the aggregation of
large amounts of information and
peer-to-peer interactions without the
technology it is much more viable to
achieve coordination very centralized
hierarchical model but has become to
quantify an account for more and more
areas of life blockchain based networks
will expand the capacities of
plug-and-play markets to all spheres of
activity social economic technological
and environments on the Internet of
value will function as the
infrastructure to the emergence of the
services economy which is currently
taking place within post-industrial
economies the move into a services
economy results in the conversion of
industrial age products into services
whereas the product based economic
paradigm was about the production and
consumption of more products as measured
by GDP a services economy is about value
delivered a service is an exchange of
value you don't get the product you just
get its function and the value that it
delivers
as such all spheres of economy become
redefined away from the static
conception of units of products towards
the more fluid exchange of value
you don't buy lift to put in your office
building you get it as a service paying
only for the functional value it
delivers in some offices now they don't
even buy the carpets on the floor the
function of the carpet is delivered as a
service and they pay only for the value
that's exchanged the blockchain is a key
infrastructure enabling this services
economy as it requires a very fluid
dynamic an automatic tracking an
exchange of value smart property and
smart contracts will form the
technological infrastructure powering
the services economy as they operate
within large peer networks automatically
allocating resources and processing the
financial debits and credits of value
exchanges behind the scenes this huge
shift in our economy lets us
reconceptualize every industry to really
question what is the actual value that
it delivers and then reconstructed by
building token markets around that value
where anyone can participate in the
delivery of the service with web 2.0 and
the platform economy we extended the
capacities of markets so that many more
people could participate as exemplified
by uber enabling anyone to operate as a
driver
however these markets were centralized
around the platform operators and they
were dependent on traditional currency
systems and the financial system for
processing transactions in web 3.0
blockchain applications will function as
distributed automatic plug-and-play
markets were extremely small increments
of value can be exchanged directly it
appear with very high levels fluidity
when this is coupled with IOT and data
analytics we'll be able to track the
real value that things deliver which
will help us to make the much-needed
move from our product based economies to
an outcomes economy the better reflects
the underlying value being created in
exchange
with the ongoing revolution in
in technology our economic systems of
organization are being transformed and
disrupted by the rise of information
networks it started with the advent of
the personal computer World Wide Web and
with the rise of online platforms the
disruptive power of information networks
to reshape economic organization became
ever more apparent today this process of
economic transformation continues with a
new set of technologies as we are
currently in the process of remaking the
technology stack of the Internet
building what is called web 3.0 a
primary component of which is the
blockchain the defining feature of this
next stage of economic development is
that it decentralizes our economy and
shifts operations to global information
based networks like never before
this distributed internet technology
stack that is currently being built
enables a network of computers to
maintain a collective database of value
ownership and exchanges via internet
protocols this bookkeeping is neither
closed nor the control of one party
rather it is public and available in one
digital ledger which is distributed
across the network the most mature
example of this is what we call the
blockchain in the blockchain all
transactions are logged including
information on the date time
participants and amount of every single
transaction on the basis of
sophisticated mathematical principles
the transactions are verified by the so
called miners who run the computing
infrastructure required to maintain the
Ledger's
the technology of web 3.0 enables a new
form of decentralized economy as it
removes the dependency on a centralized
authority for managing the network
instead replacing it with a distributed
consensus model managed by many this
shared securely encrypted database
enables trustless peer-to-peer
interactions via new internet protocols
people can begin to set up their own
networks for coordination and direct
exchanges of value peer-to-peer and it
enables the rules of these transactions
to be automated in new ways
at the heart of this system is the
distributed ledger which records the
exchanges of value these distributed
Ledger's can account for and validate
the exchange of any form of value it may
be a currency it may be property it may
be a kilowatt hour of energy the usage
of a parking spot the number of
followers a person has on social media
these distributed Ledger's provide the
infrastructure for building token
economies a token is simply a quantified
unit of value tokens are both generic
and fungible it is generic in that it
can be used to define any form of value
and it is fungible meaning it is
exchangeable between different specific
forms of value
traditional monetary currencies are not
fully fungible as there are many
circumstances when one cannot exchange a
monetary currency for other forms of
value for example likes on social media
may have a certain value but typically
cannot be directly exchanged for
monetary currencies
a token differs from our traditional
monetary currency and that it is more
generic our existing currencies define a
particular type of monetary value what
we call utility which is based upon the
economic logic of the industrial economy
while tokens because they are more
generic can define a broader set of
values social capital natural capital or
cultural capital for example natural
capital is the integrity of an ecosystem
that enables it to function and provide
ecosystems services to people in our
traditional economic model we only
quantify and account for the services
that the ecosystem delivers such as food
water materials etc however we do not
account for the integrity of the
ecosystem that enables it to function
the generic nature of the token means it
can be used to account for values such
as this natural capital
the capacity to differentiate between
different forms of value is made
possible by the programmability of token
units because tokens are digital
they are also programmable which enables
one to specify certain rules for that
token and have those rules executed when
it is exchanged thus enabling certain
constraints or possibilities in its
usage one can specify that a certain
token is only spendable under certain
terms or specify how it can be converted
for example one could program the token
so that it cannot be exchanged for
diamonds that are mined in a particular
location of the world known for its use
of slave labor in this way the token is
not just a unit of utility but also
expresses social values
likewise one could create a health care
allowance in dollars or Euros that could
be programmed on the blockchain so that
it can only be used to pay for health
care at certified parties automating
these measures leads to a considerable
decrease in bureaucracy this
programmable token system works to shift
our economies from a single value model
to a multi value model they create many
different types of value and economies
but still retain the possibility for
exchange between them
the distributed web is the convergence
of the economic market system with
information technology that enables us
to convert traditional organizations
into distributed markets based on tokens
tokens define whatever is a value within
that organization and the market system
is used as a distributed coordination
mechanism for managing and growing that
resource
by creating an expanded definition of
value and converting closed
organizations into open markets this
means that we can vastly expand the
scope and capacities of the economy the
provisioning of services within the
economy no longer becomes dependent upon
a limited number of centralized
organizations acting for profit but
instead anyone can now provide the
service via these open protocols this
means we can harness the resources of
the many in a distributed fashion
instead of being dependent upon a few
likewise the token economy can harness
the motives of individuals not just for
financial rewards but for a multiplicity
of values
to illustrate how this works let's think
about the service of cloud data storage
currently this is provided by a limited
number of enterprises like Amazon and
Microsoft these centralized
organizations have huge data centers but
still those data centers are only a very
small fraction of the storage capacity
in the world most of the storage is in
the personal computing devices of
end-users and most of that is not being
used a file coin is one organization
that works to create a distributed token
economy for this storage file coin is a
decentralized storage network that turns
cloud storage into an algorithmic market
the market runs on a blockchain with a
native protocol token also called file
coin which miners earned by providing
storage to clients
conversely clients spend file coins
hiring miners to store or distribute
data the sum of all these computers that
are coordinated through an automatic
market system on the blockchain can
provide a much larger more resilient
system than the centralized model while
reducing redundancy and inefficiencies
in the overall system it also pushes the
provision of the service out to the
location where it is demanded as people
are connecting peer-to-peer locally
instead of going to the centralized
server that may be on the other side of
the planet
tokens such as file coins can be
exchanged for other currencies or
members can hold on to their tokens
whose value may appreciate as the
networks grow over time
this illustrates a very interesting
aspect to tokens anyone who uses the
system is also an investor in the system
thus tokens merge investment capital and
liquid exchange capital in new ways in
the traditional capitalist model we have
a divide between owners of capital and
workers a divide between a more fixed
investment capital and liquid exchange
currencies the shares in a company are
not the same thing as what people get
paid with for working in that enterprise
and use for everyday exchanges in the
market this creates the notorious divide
within the industrial economy described
by Karl Marx between the capitalists
that make money off their investments in
the workers that have to stay selling
their labor for money without ownership
tokens represent both the inherent value
of the community which is its capital
investment and they are also units of
exchange within that ecosystem the
founders of the project issue a number
of tokens at inception and sell those
for someone to use the system they have
to buy the tokens in so doing they
become part investors in the project but
they also use those same tokens to make
exchanges within the market thus the
people creating the value in the
ecosystem are also getting paid in
tokens meaning the workers that are
creating the value through their work
also have ownership within the
organization
in the traditional utility-based
exchange of cash people have no
ownership in the organization they just
try to make money and this can create
divides between the owners and the users
the token system works to better align
the incentives of the individuals with
the overall system because the value of
the tokens they earn is also dependent
upon the value of the whole when you are
working for a token network you are both
working for yourself and for the whole
organization as the to become more
aligned unlike the traditional divide
between capitalist and worker
the token system enables networks to
overcome the chicken-and-egg problem if
you are the first user of a network like
eBay then the value would be very low
thus it is difficult to get the network
started because it has to reach a
critical mass before it will be of value
to the users this means that it may
require a large investment to create a
network the Silicon Valley model worked
by having large initial venture capital
backing that enables them to overcome
this but it means that most networks
don't get off the ground and that once a
network reaches scale and has value it
becomes dominant and very difficult to
compete with resulting in a lock-in
effect and making it easy for large
incumbent organizations to become
extractive over time it also means that
those who founded the organization win
big time if the network takes off it
creates a winner-takes-all dynamic with
most people losing because of the
threshold
the token system extends the benefits of
being an early adopter of a new network
to all the users and thus helps to solve
this issue it does this by issuing
tokens for anyone to purchase at the
beginning of the project as the project
grows the tokens come to have greater
value for all of the holders
this also works to make the users of the
network promoters of that organization
because as it grows the tokens that they
hold become more valuable it
incentivizes people to join networks
early so as to gain the benefits of the
increase in their token value as it
grows which reduces the problem of
thresholds with this technology
companies no longer have to go to
traditional capital markets through an
initial public offering of shares in the
company in exchange for money but
instead they simply sell tokens directly
on the Internet to raise initial capital
for the project in what is called an
initial coin offering or IC o----
this means that founders can monetize
their networks directly by simply
holding their tokens and making the
network useful
to date we have had an Internet patched
onto the side of an economy operated
through the many centralized
organizations of the Industrial Age
creating a strong contradiction between
the underlying technology and the
institutional arrangements the
distributed web will work to transform
this by merging information networks and
economic organization as the flow of
information an economic value becomes
one this will greatly reduce our
dependency on centralized organizations
expanding markets as systems of
organization the global market economy
will become available to the many
through small distributed peer-to-peer
interactions running through web
protocols as the decentralized internet
takes us a step further into the
networked economy
[Music]